and the spirit of thankfulness I'd like
to celebrate America's greatest
generation old people we respect the
brave elders who fought for our country
whether on the field of battle or the
field of real estate while bravely
nursing bone spurs we can learn so much
from the very old that's why I put an ad
in yelling at cars that go too fast
quarterly to announce our opposition
learn from someone near the grave before
it's too late contest
we got literally tens of entries from
the elderly all all across the country
who sent in a hundred UPC symbols from
the bottom of CHOP position bran bone
condenser bottles our winner was
selected at random let's bring them out
and see what we can learn from this
grizzled old timer please welcome John s
from New Jersey
[Applause]
don't help me I'm not going to do this
my SATs what I'm not that old I'm just
gestured just saying you sit for God's
sakes it's exhausting night nice to meet
you did you did you really eat a hundred
bottles of bone can I thank you bomb
condenser you like it's very tasty you
know me I like chalky and let's face
facts my bones could use condensing yeah
I have very wide loose points except
that I've already loose and wide I've
always thought your bones are
surprisingly sparse thank you
well my card says here you're from New
Jersey I'm gonna act like we're the same
height if that's all you want to move it
up is this it's fine it's how does it
feel no no no that you're not even told
about some oh hi somebody else can be
can I tell you how it feels honestly yes
it feels I feel you don't have a pill
for that day and now all you can do is
condense my bones that's fine you said
across me for years
I did sit across from you for you you
wanted me to be low I did you're always
weird about how high I was and you were
like you should be low because honestly
a person like you I don't normally see
unless they're eating foliage from the
world it's not something that I normally
so what the hell are you we're doing a
benefit we're doing a lovely benefit
it's a called night of too many stars
it's gonna have a tremendous amount to
many stars we're going to raise money
for it next for autism they provide
services for those with autism and their
families that's all we're doing nothing
more to it than that no conspiracy about
anything else just raising money for
people 92 many stars HBO Saturday
November 18th 8 o'clock this guy knows
this this guy knows what I'm talking
about oh these people don't know these
they don't know these they're not here
for the bunk you don't know these people
who is who is at this thing Stars big
stars too many too many stars Chris Rock
yeah is that that whoo they were
impressed
I got woosh prints we are getting whoosh
for these people is not hot hate people
woo I didn't even say it in a nice way
and they just did it I just want to say
something that is how Hitler started
started out he had a talk show he got
people to woo the next thing you know
hey why don't we all go visit Poland you
come under my show and you're already
connecting me to Hitler I don't need
this we're just starting this show I'm a
white guy on late-night and you come on
this show and you connect me to Hitler
Jesus Christ do you out now we used to
have and I don't know if you guys have
this an editor we are a start-up John
this all goes out don't you think don't
you know about modern TV it's all about
content we just push everything I don't
know about that my point is just huge
stars from from Chris Rock to Adam
Sandler to Olivia Munn to the broad city
ladies to Robert De Niro to Bobby day
the roots are gonna be the roots yeah
roots roots I want in what I love the
roots to me on my way semia mo
I wanted you know what I'm gonna run up
here I'm gonna do something nice for you
all right I'm gonna do something nice
you know what guess what imma do I want
to support an extra autism by giving one
lucky freethinker the chance to hang out
with me this is a fact and by hang out I
mean I'm gonna take you up in an actual
black helicopter so we can to New York
City and look down on all the coastal
elites we'll make them look up at us for
a change that's right I'm making New
York City flyover country so go online
right now to amaze calm slash Jordan
you'll have a chance to win the most
badass experience in the whole contest a
helicopter ride over New York City with
me could could I borrow your Illuminati
helices I know God Stuart everybody
[Applause]
[Music]